new facts are emerging out of the texas
elementary school where that awful
shooting took place this week and these
new facts somehow make the whole thing
even more horrible because they suggest
that the horror might have been
prevented we're talking about simple
facts here
the doors to the school were unlocked
the killer entered through an
unmonitored door in the back
there was no armed guard on duty
anywhere on the school premises
had even just those circumstances been
different of course it's no guarantee
that the shooter would have been stopped
or that the death toll would have been
lower
but it certainly would have reduced the
likelihood that the shooter could have
done what he did
and it's precisely these sorts of facts
that activists in the media are trying
to deny
i say this this tonight with the hope
not with an expectation but with the
hope
that people like ted cruz and greg
abbott and john cornyn people who were
elected by texans will actually listen
to it instead of going right to gun
control laws don't work and we need
armed teachers and guards at schools if
your solution to children being
massacred is armed guards
you haven't been paying attention to
what's going on
there was an armed guard in buffalo
there was an armed guard in parkland
there was an armed guard in uvalde they
had armed guards
so what jimmy kimmel just said is not
true it's not true with with regard to
this shooting that we just saw in texas
it's i'm not even saying he's lying he
probably just doesn't know
but that falsehood and for some people
that lie
is essential to the agenda and the
agenda here is not so much about
improving the safety of schools as it is
about enacting the mostly unrelated gun
control laws that liberals have wanted
for decades all the very same laws that
as even the washington post admits
wouldn't have stopped the mass shootings
there are lots of gun laws that
democrats want and that republicans and
voters more broadly actually will never
let them pass
for sure there are
there are plenty of gun laws that
republicans want that democrats won't
let them pass that's true too
but then there are really basic laws
that theoretically could be passed
that would go a long way toward
protecting schools funding armed guards
upgrading school buildings to better
secure the doors these are not
particularly ideological reforms these
are not an opportunity to score big
partisan points these are just basic
safety precautions to protect schools
which is why we are almost certainly not
going to get them i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from bld who says
quote there will always be a big fat
samoan lady who is fatter than you is
the most inspiring quote i've heard in a
long time thank you very much you know i
hope that someday
i can have enough
words of wisdom pearls of true wisdom
that drop from my lips that someone can
put them all together in a book of
quotations and i hope that one
is is right there at the top of the list
when we're thinking about our victimhood
when we're thinking of the the fatness
victim chart of tick-tock
there will always be a fat samoan lady
somewhere who is fatter than you you can
take that one to the bank you can tell
your friends when you want to tell your
friends that you got to pick up puretalk
right now go to puretalk.com promo code
knowles podcast i absolutely love my
pure talk i've got my pure talk phone it
is my favorite phone service i've ever
had i've used a lot of the other guys
but the problem is verizon att t-mobile
they're making it clear that they care
more about selling wokeness than
wireless
they're making you fund their agenda
with overpriced contracts and hidden
fees why are why are we giving these
people our money when there's an
alternative the alternative is pure talk
just choose puretalk instead just like
daily wires offering alternatives to
woke entertainment media puretalk is
offering alternatives to woke wireless
networks the pure talk ceo is a us
veteran the service team is located
right here in america which is a little
touch that i love you never compromise
on service i was actually a little
curious i was a little skeptical i said
i don't know is this really going to be
the greatest network you know unlimited
talk unlimited text unlimited data i'm
skeptical i try out my pure talk it's
amazing just as great as the other guys
way way cheaper and and it's a company
that believes in your values go to
puretalk.com shop for the plan that's
right for you puretalk.com promo code
knowles podcast save fifty five zero
percent off your first month noel's
podcast canon wlas
p-o-d-c-a-s-t all one word at
puretalk.com puretalk is simply
smarter
wireless
go check out puretalk today
not everything has to be
an extreme partisan fight
practically speaking i guess it does
these days but it shouldn't have to be a
big partisan fight there are some really
basic
things about society that we can all
agree on
i would hope at least that until very
recently we could all agree on
a leftist would not want to use this
tumbler to drink delicious tears or
sparkling water or whatever you're
drinking right they wouldn't want to use
this tumbler because it says leftist
tears just like i wouldn't want to use a
tumbler that says conservative tears
but at the very least we should both be
able to agree that you should drink
sparkling water out of a cup rather than
out of i don't know a kazoo
right there there are basic facts about
reality that we should all be able to
agree on that don't necessarily need to
have a republican color or a democrat
color or a left or right or not
everything has to be about ideology
the reason it feels like it does is
because the left's political program
is about upending society the left's
political program is essentially
revolutionary that's been true not just
for the past 20 years it's been true
going back to the french revolution it's
been it's been true further back than
that that we've got to remake the whole
world anew
and and all
of the inherited wisdom of the past it's
not wisdom it's all it's it's terrible
it's awful it's bigoted it's it's making
us all miserable we got to get rid of it
but there is a lot of wisdom in the past
we actually have learned things over the
history of humanity really basic things
it doesn't necessarily need to be about
rights and entitlement and high-minded
philosophy it can just be hey lock the
doors
hey lock the doors when you want to stay
safe hey have single points of entry hey
have people whose job it is to protect
other people when they're a soft target
really really simple stuff there was a
an interview in chicago took place
yesterday or the day before this was
conducted by a fox affiliate in chicago
so not not fox news the center-right
news channel but just a regular old
network affiliate
they're conducting the interview on the
street about guns in chicago during the
interview some dude comes out and
brandishes a pistol at the cameraman
around seven o'clock this morning at the
corner of clark and hubbard while our
reporter was in the middle of a live
report about gun violence in chicago a
man walked up and pointed what appeared
to be a firearm at our crew right now
police are calling this man a person of
interest accused of aggravated assault
with a firearm
this guy who brandished the gun on the
street at the reporter he doesn't look
like he's been living on the street for
the past two years he doesn't look like
necessarily some schizophrenic drug
addicted derelict roaming the streets
he's fairly well dressed he seems fairly
clean
he's
he doesn't seem sane in that no sane
person should be brandishing a weapon on
the street but really he just seems
he seems bold
he seems like he knows there aren't
going to be any consequences for this
kind of behavior and why because there
won't be
because throughout many of our major
cities
run by leftists people are not arrested
for crimes
because for the past two years the left
has run on defunding the police and
abolishing police departments and
installing far-left da's that just won't
prosecute people for crime and then
during covet they emptied out the jails
and they just say we're they're they're
sending a message to the criminals hey
do whatever you want we're not going to
stop you so is it any wonder that people
like this are emboldened in chicago do
you know what would stop this kind of
behavior it doesn't need to be some pie
in the sky really extremely
sophisticated ideological thing
arrest the criminals arrest him that
dude should be nabbed immediately he
should go to jail for a long time he
should be punished not just a little
plea deal slap on the hand well society
failed him well he had a tough
upbringing and let's just divert him
into a nice special non-profit program
where no punish him he's a bad guy and
if you don't want him to remain a bad
guy if you want him to become a better
guy then punish him
enforce basic laws is that so much to
ask these days i guess it is
because because none of the people now
who are clamoring do something do
something do something
none of them seem to care at all about
fixing the problems that they're
claiming to want to fix they're all just
pushing the same old ideological agenda
that they were pushing
ten months ago two years ago ten years
ago joe biden now
has gone off and
made this entire effort to which should
be about protecting schools into an
effort to ban ar-15s
no one needs an ar-15
something designed for no other purpose
none other than to kill human beings
there's no other rationale for its
existence
and to kill them as quickly and as
brutally as possible
it's not exactly true because you can
kill squirrels with an ar-15 or you
could ether i think you could even kill
deer though it wouldn't be particularly
uh humane
but to his
it's also
ar-15s are not the quickest way to kill
people because they're not contrary to
what the left would have you believe
they're not fully automatic weapons
they're not assault rifles right fully
automatic weapon you pull the trigger
and a spray of bullets comes out a
semi-automatic weapon you pull the
trigger one bullet comes out you pull
the trigger again another bullet comes
out so
what he's saying technically is is not
true
but to his broader point he says these
guns kill people
and and he's implying that that's a bad
thing for guns to do that is the purpose
of guns that is the purpose of the
second amendment that is the purpose of
the right to self-defense
is that if someone comes to attack you
you have the right to defend yourself
that's what they're for people are not
buying these guns to go hunt squirrels
and he's insinuating that this is a bad
thing
what is his solution what is his
solution
if he's saying that the problem with the
ar-15 is they're designed to kill people
then that means we have to get rid of
all the guns
but not just the ar-15s handguns are
designed to kill people
in fact handguns are much more directly
designed to kill people than any of the
rifles are or any of the shotguns are
so then you have to get rid of all the
guns are you going to do that joe biden
no you'd have to repeal the second
amendment are you going to do that no
you can't do that and most people don't
want you to do that
so what are you going to do are you
going to
are you going to pass laws
in contravention of the second amendment
are you going to try to change the
interpretation of the second amendment
are you going you're going to just
confiscate all the guns without
repealing the second amendment there are
more guns than people in america so what
is the practical effect of what he's
proposing
nothing
philosophically it's incoherent
constitutionally it's incoherent legally
it's incoherent but even put all that
aside those are the ideological debates
and the phyllis
just practically it's not going to
happen it's completely
fantastical
so then what does he do he's not doing
anything he's running his mouth and he's
trying to score cheap campaign points
but in practice he is accomplishing
absolutely nothing productive when you
want to be productive you got to make
sure you get a good night's sleep that's
why you got to check out helix
right now go to helixsleep.com
knowles i have had my helix now for what
two years i think and i love it i
absolutely love this thing one it was so
simple to order you just go you take
this two minute sleep quiz to match the
mattress to you it's a mattress for you
not for somebody else for you it then
comes right to your door it's super easy
to set up and it feels
great i absolutely love this helix
they've got soft medium firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot mattress is great for
spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus sized sleepers you
take that quiz it takes two minutes they
match you to that mattress and then it
comes right to your door they've got a
10 year warranty you can try it out for
a hundred nights risk free they will
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it you will love it they've got
financing options they've got flexible
payment plans for a limited time right
now they're giving you 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is their best offer
yet so hurry on over to helix sleep.com
knowles
go check out helix today
now the libs are not they're not just
exploiting the the tragedy to push the
same old laws that are
somewhat related to the tragedy but
largely unrelated the same old gun laws
now they're exploiting it to push their
views of abortion julia ioff who's a
blue check journal
a liberal journalist
though basically i repeat myself right
when you say journalist usually you're
referring to a liberal she just tweeted
out quote what if you could perform an
abortion with an ar-15
you would defend ar-15s
i guess
what point is she trying to make here
what if you could perform an abortion
with an air well actually you can
perform an abortion with an ar-15
strictly speaking probably not safest
for the mother but you could what is an
abortion abortion is killing a little
baby
so you you could what what point is she
making here
i think she's undermining her own
argument but she's trying to insinuate
that republicans care very much about
babies when they're in the womb but they
don't care about children we're out when
they're outside the womb because if they
cared about children outside the womb
they would ban ar-15s even though
banning ar-15s would have
almost certainly zero effect on any of
these mass shooting incidents
even though banning ar-15s which we did
by the way we did it in the 90s and it
just didn't do anything to the murder
rate
even though
these claims ban the ar-15s and all of
the other proposals that the democrats
have made in recent years
would not have stopped the mass
shootings as even the washington post
admits so what point are you making
well well republicans are bad it's all
this vague insinuation without any facts
whatsoever it's all just this do
something do so what do you want to do
yelling do something
and mocking people for offering their
prayers
does not make you virtuous
it's no more productive than the people
who are trying to do something and
perhaps failing
it's certainly no more productive than
them
it's far less productive i think
and it's far more crass because you're
you're exploiting
an incident that we should all agree is
tragic and there might be something some
really basic safety precautions we could
do to at least
amp up the safety of the schools and
you're using that and you're ignoring
the proposals to make the schools safer
and you're just moving on to get to your
regular old hobby horse and get to your
regular old pet project in politics
in this case abortion which is entirely
unrelated
but they're so obsessed with abortion
because they know
how bad this makes them look
they're so obsessed with abortion
because they know that abortion is the
logical conclusion of their entire
political agenda which is about
liberation and
and
individual autonomy and selfishness
ultimately me me me i will do whatever i
want aleister crowley said that what was
the line
uh
to do
to do your will is the entirety of the
law do what thou wilt and that is the
entirety of the law it's a it's a
hideous perversion inversion of
christianity
and it just boils down to what we all
know the left is after which is
selfishness i mean i me my i me my and
they know that that's the logical
conclusion they know that that's ugly at
a really basic level be selfish is not
is not a persuasive political platform
but they have to keep defending it
especially now
that abortion is potentially about to be
restricted
there was a gallon tick tock
i didn't believe this was legitimate at
first a gal on tick-tock
breastfeeding her child
defending abortion
i could have killed you
but i chose to let you live
i chose to let her live as in i had a
choice
all women should have a choice do you
realize what you're just saying killed i
cannot wrap my brain around this don't
matter how i look at it if you don't
want to use the word killed that's fine
if you want to use the word kill that's
fine when you use hand sanitizer you
kill germs i could have simply chosen to
let you not exist
but i let you exist i let you form past
the zygote phase
is that better
so yes i realized what i just said and i
stand by it if you want to get an
abortion get an abortion if you don't
want to get an abortion don't get an
abortion but don't try to oppress my
rights
you gotta hand it to her this stone cold
psycho is at least being honest about
the whole thing
she's saying right now
i could have killed you and i chose not
to kill you
and i know you pro-abortion people out
there you fellow pro-abortion people you
don't want me to use the word kill you
want me to use some other euphemism and
she kind of makes fun of the euphemisms
i let you form past the zygote phase
which of course the zygote is refers to
the extremely brief period of time when
a baby is a single cell and then it
almost instantly is no longer a zygote
whatever is like you can use whatever
euphemism you want you're still talking
about the same living human being she
says okay i can use all these euphemisms
but it just means kill right and yeah
that's what we should be defending
that's what abortion is and i want my
right my license to kill the baby and i
in this case i chose not to but my
choice my
exercise of the will absent all reason
and justice is the most important
political value and that's that
and if you don't like it tough
she is saying the quiet part out loud
and it is extremely disturbing to watch
her say it period but certainly say it
while breastfeeding and certainly say it
to her baby
but that's it that's that's what the
logic of abortion is
and
i thank her i am indebted to her for
for not hiding it and not not trying to
deceive everybody no that's it
if you find that appealing then you
support abortion if you find that
ghastly and unthinkable then you're
pro-life and maybe you haven't worked
out all the abstract and all the really
high sophisticated philosophy and
biology but if you recoil at that video
and you say whoa man this is wrong
you are pro-life
just as this gal has followed her
pro-abortion
ideas to their logical conclusion you
just need to follow your pro-life
instincts to their logical conclusion
not just her there was a gal
she's a blm activist andy no my friend
andy noah just pointed this out
yesterday
she's on twitter by the name hidden
agenda
and she i'm not going to read all of
this she sent out a long narrative of
her getting an abortion but here's what
here's what she said
she said
i didn't know when i was going to be
ready to share my story but i guess i
was never going to be ready just effing
angry so here goes nothing i got an
abortion and it saved my effing life
then she says
she uh showed up and she was told that
she was about 26 27 weeks pregnant then
goes update
checked my my chart to confirm and i was
27 weeks and six days closer to 28 weeks
pregnant
this is
a pretty much almost exactly as pregnant
as sweet little alisa is right now with
our baby who's kicking all the time
who's moving all the time who's
responding to a ton of stimuli who is
a fully formed baby
when you're 28 weeks pregnant you are
very very formed you are identifiably
human and living in every single way and
she says she went in and she said i want
an abortion and there were only a few
places where that is even still legal
even today in america
she got the shot to
kill the baby a shot through her stomach
and then she says monday january 17th
2022 at approximately 6 30 p.m
after a grueling night filled with so
much pain that i needed an epidural
morphine and fentanyl i gave birth to a
just over two pounds seven inch girl
with no heartbeat
and
she wanted this
she couldn't wait another
was it 36 weeks you can deliver she
couldn't wait another
eight weeks to deliver the bait this
baby that she hated her own child and
just give the baby up for adoption to
the many many many couples who are
trying to adopt she wouldn't do that she
said no i'm not going to allow you to
live
it wasn't even about avoiding birth i'm
i'm at least glad that this woman has
has debunked the lie
that pro-lifers are are in favor of
forced birth and that abortion somehow
allows you to avoid birth no this woman
didn't avoid birth she said she gave
birth to a baby girl
the only difference is that the baby
girl that she gave birth to was dead
because she had already killed her but
she she still gave birth
she just
so hated this baby
and was so insistent on exercising her
will her selfish will
even to the point of killing others
even to the point of killing her own
child that she was willing to give birth
and go through exactly all the same
pain and all the same discomfort
for a dead baby
this is the conclusion that drew clavin
talks about this talk about logical
conclusions he says that one of the
things that brought him back to
christianity was actually the marquis de
sade the marquis de sade is where we get
the word sadism from he's one of
probably the most famous psycho in the
history of the world and he was a
pornographer and a killer and a psycho
and also a
philosopher a philosopher of
torture and sadism and selfishness
and
at the bottom of the marquis assad's
philosophy is this one question why
why is your pain any more important than
my pleasure
why should i care about you at all even
to the point of torture even to the
point
of death
if i want something why do i have to
care about any of that even to the point
of killing my own kid
well she's following that to its logical
conclusion
getting rid of all the all the
propaganda all the fake facts it's not a
baby the baby's not alive the baby's not
a person the baby doesn't have to be
born no she's saying no that none of
that's true this is a human human baby
i'm giving birth
i just
i just want to kill it if you recoil at
that
just as this woman has followed abortion
to its logical conclusion if you recoil
in any way you are pro-life just follow
those views to their logical conclusion
it's evil stuff
it's evil it's the only way you can
describe that
i there's no
just totally clinical neutral language
we can use to describe the pistons
firing in the brain
and the no it's just evil okay good and
evil are real
they're much they're much more real than
a lot of our scientific jargon that we
use to deny these basic things that we
all know to be true
good and evil the things that people
intuit the moral realities that people
intuit you using their common sense
are much more real
than the jargony abstractions that we
all cook up in our post-modern
philosophy and sociology
and the left wants to deny good and evil
because the left's program is
revolutionary the left's program is
undoing upending everything that has
been established
you really see marx take this to its
logical conclusion in its fullest
expression when karl marx says that he
wants to engage in the ruthless
criticism of all that exists
which is where we get things like
critical theory from critical race
theory we hear a lot of a critical legal
theory that this withering ruthless
criticism of everything all that exists
everything in society not just the laws
but the customs not just the customs but
the institutions not just the
institutions but the family the basic
institution not just the family but
human nature itself sex boys and girls
the way we relate to each one another
the way we relate to ourselves all of
that has to be upended and in order to
do that you have to deny the reality of
good and evil true and false right and
wrong which we all can interpret this is
why gavin newsom
governor of california i think
unwittingly
it gave away the democrats game here in
responding to the shooting that took
place in texas
governor abbott greg abbott of texas
talked about the realities of evil and
the dangers of mental illness and the
dangers of isolation and loneliness and
the problems of community fracture and
losing some of these basic common sense
measures that can protect the community
and gavin newsom all the way from
california decided to take pot shots at
him for having the audacity the gall to
mention evil
do not give in to the cynicism
and all the crap
that you heard today in that press
conference
around evil and mental health
that completely blinds
the fact that there's only one nation on
planet earth
that separates itself from all other
nations
and that's the united states of america
and the perversion
of a second amendment that begins around
well regulated
well regulated
gun policy
so what he said factually there is not
true and you hear it repeated a lot by
the left which is that the united states
is the only it's the outlier in the
whole world we have more mass killings
than anybody it's not even close and the
only reason for that is because we have
guns here
the claim is just not true
it's not true when you adjust for
population we have a pretty large
population when you adjust for
population size we're actually kind of
toward the middle of the pack when you
look at mass killing incidents when you
look at rates of violent crime and
murder we're
far closer to the middle of the pack
in the 40s in the 50s than we are number
one far and away that's not true so the
libs are manipulating statistics to make
that claim that's what he's doing there
but forget about the statistics you know
i don't really believe in statistics i'm
happy to cite them when they back up my
opinion as they do just now but
you have your statistics i have my
statistics and there are lies damn lies
and statistics the craziest thing that
that newsom just said there is
ignore the cynicism you heard today
about the realities of evil
he's saying that to talk about evil is
to be cynical
when in fact that is the opposite of
cynicism
cynicism is indifference toward the
truth cynicism is the denial of truth
you see the perfect example of cynicism
when christ is before pontius pilate
and
christ says i am the truth and pontius
pilate says
what is truth
that is the
perfect expression of cynicism what is
truth that that's what gavin newsom's
saying he said what is evil
what is what is good and bad
what is true and false
what is what is evil come on
what is goodness you're using those
silly old terms no that's not real we're
just talking about statistics
that that is cynicism he is the cynical
guy which is no surprise of course
because the libs always project the libs
are always accusing their opponents of
the things that they themselves are
doing
how cynical how
the only reason
the only thing that might mitigate his
culpability here is that gavin newsom
probably doesn't even understand the
irony of what he's saying but he is the
one pushing cynicism here
there woe to those who call good evil
and evil good
and you're seeing it in the elementary
schools there was an elementary school
in wisconsin
which is now
investigating a school counselor
for quote-unquote immoral conduct
what was the immoral conduct
this counselor opposes
not just transgenderism
but opposes
transiting the kids
and this is considered immoral by the
school
melissa
darling received a letter from the
wisconsin department of public
instruction
uh april 29th warning her that her state
issued license could be revoked if the
investigation finds she engaged in
immoral conduct at a rally
they want to determine
whether she said f transgenderism on
video and whether she said that she does
not believe that children should have
access to cross-sex hormones or surgery
that's the more i don't think the
immoral conduct is that she said the f
word i suspect every every teacher at
that school and every staff member at
that school has used the f word at some
point it's that she said i you do not
believe that children should be put on
cross-sex hormones and have their bodies
mutilated that's considered immoral
of course it is immoral to do that to
children it is moral not to do that to
children it's not there's no neutrality
here it's not just that they've said
look we're gonna we're gonna keep an
open mind and be very liberal no they
took the old standard which is
mutilating kids bodies and confusing
them sexually is wrong
and they said no that's right
and not doing that is wrong disney plus
is doing this we will get to the mailbag
i'm always running late as per usual
disney plus
disney got dragged for promoting the
weird sex stuff with the little kids
disney right now
is doubling down on that and and
producing drag queen content for little
kids on disney plus
hello
and welcome to the disney plus this is
me pride celebration spectacular i'm
nina west and i'm here to guide you
through a magical musical and
meaningful celebration of the lgbtq plus
community glsen's mission is to create
safe and inclusive schools for lgbtq
plus students in grades k-12 and disney
plus is so proud to support this
wonderful organization for more
information visit www.glsen.org
forward slash pride
what are you going to do about it
they've already been dragged through the
mud disney and they don't care they're
doubling down on trying to
pervert the kids they're doubling down
on pushing perverted sexual ideologies
on little kids
and they're saying this is totally
neutral this is look this is neutral
we're not pushing a moral view one way
or the other it's just this is open it's
liberal it's inclusive it's diverse how
cynical do you have to be to say that
sort of thing
woe to those who call good evil evil
good
if you
if you believe that there is no moral
component here if you believe that you
can just live in a totally neutral world
where the realities of right and wrong
and good and bad and and true and false
don't matter
then you are as naive as can you you're
so naive you could believe gavin newsom
you're so naive that you could believe
joe biden and the rest of these people
who are pushing their radical moral
agenda
on you
and and for so long the conservatives
just roll over they don't even know that
it's happening you know for countless
actors and comedians in hollywood who
dare to push the wrong sequence of keys
on their phone
or breathe the wrong way into a
microphone
they pay with their careers torn away
from them by a savage woke mob like my
friend gina carano gina carano tweeted
unthinkable thoughts
such as neighbors should be nice to each
other
and elections should be fair she was
immediately thrown out of the cast of
the mandalorian she was banished from
the magical kingdom
the whole thing
was an atrocity and at the daily wire we
will not stand for it that's why we
fought back by hiring gina and starring
her in our new summer blockbuster terror
on the prairie which premieres
exclusively on the daily wire on june
14th set on the plains of montana this
gritty thriller follows a family of
pioneers as they defend themselves from
a vicious gang of outlaws hell-bent on
revenge we are giving you a sneak peek
next week when the trailer will drop on
june 1st to top it all off the official
terror on the prayer movie poster is in
our shop right now go to dailywire.com
shop become a member today dailywire.com
shop we also have my favorite time of
the week coming up the mailbag sponsored
by puretalk i love puretalk because they
have a great service and they great
phones and they're terrific but
even more than that somehow even more
than that i love pure talk because
they're sponsoring our new voicemail bag
so that you can send your voicemails
into the show and i get to hear your
dulcet tones go to puretalk.com enter
promo code noel's podcast to say 50 off
your first month let's get to the first
voicemail bag
hi michael huge fan of the show i just
wanted to get your take on something
i recently found this book titled good
grief rituals and while i was optimistic
when i first came across it
it didn't take me long to realize that a
lot of these quote rituals were
hippie-dippy tree-hugging something
you'd find at the bottom of anthony
kennedy's bong
so with that being said
i wanted to ask you
how do you use religion christianity to
help you deal with grief and loss
um because that's something i've always
struggled with
you don't use it first of all
there's a quote of c.s lewis that i go
back to again and again because it's so
good he says if you look for truth you
might find comfort in the end if you
look for comfort you will find neither
truth nor comfort only soft soap and
wishful thinking to begin and in the end
despair
it's one thing to lecture on how to deal
with grief on a sunny day
this is what c.s lewis actually did in
his book the problem of pain
it's another thing to deal with grief in
real life which is something that c.s
lewis acknowledged in his book a grief
observed talking about the death of his
wife
when i was in high school i had to deal
with a grief
and
i was an atheist and i remained
atheistic and agnostic for some time
after that but i did find myself in the
same position you were in i i was
looking how do i process this grief how
do i deal with it what do i do you just
want to talk to the person again you you
know you have all of these natural
longings and when you start searching
in our secular confused age you end up
with all of these hippy dippy really
bizarre sometimes occult sometimes
scientistic sometimes really out there
kind of
rituals and none of it is satisfying and
none of it is coherent
religion christianity will
will help you to deal with grief it
won't erase grief
grief is just a part of the human
condition jesus wept it's the shortest
verse of the bible he wept at the death
of his friend lazarus
two seconds before he raises lazarus
from the dead that tells you something
about the reality of grief the the
inevitability of grief in this world
but it will help you to make sense of it
because true religion makes sense that's
what makes it true religion
and and that's what makes sense for uh
for that matter
so
in a very straightforward way
how do i process grief now my savior
lives i have confidence that
good triumphs over evil i have
confidence in the immortality of the
human soul i have confidence in
salvation
for those who
who seek it
or not even those who seek it those who
cooperate with god's grace i i have
confidence in that i think that those
are facts that's why hope is not merely
wishful thinking that's why hope is not
just soft optimism hope is a theological
virtue and a fact grounded not just on
poetry and and aphorisms but grounded on
the journalism of the gospel so
that grounds my hope but it does not
mean
that you will avoid grief it's not a get
out of jail free card you will have to
deal with that it reminds me of that
distinction that a priest friend of mine
father george rutler made between
optimism and pessimism he says he said
that the difference between a scottish
optimist and a scottish pessimist is
that a scottish
pessimist says things can't get any
worse and a scottish optimist says oh
yes they can in a way what religion does
what christianity does is it it gives
you hope
because it tells you how bad things
really are
and it doesn't sugarcoat that okay it
tells you the reality of how bad things
are things are so bad that god had to
send his only begotten son to the world
to be tortured and killed
to save the world and that's that's how
he treated him
so that ain't sure that ain't sugar
coating anything
but there is a happy ending which is why
on easter when we were talking about
eternal life and the resurrection this
is why on easter
christians chant oh happy fault the
fault the fall of man in the garden of
eden oh happy fault that won for us so
great so glorious redeemer even in your
grief that can give one i can point
one's eyes up toward hope
next voicemail bag
hey michael this is thomas longtime
listener first time mailbag submitter
i have an idea about the abortion
conversation which i want to run by you
i think it was confirmed by your talk
with the woman a couple weeks ago
it seems to me that it's an unproductive
conversation to have with anyone who has
a strong belief on the issue now i say
that because you're either talking to
another pro-lifer and you're preaching
to the choir or you're talking to a
die-hard abortionist who i would say has
a fundamentally incompatible view of
reality
we believe that abortion kills a living
human being and that that is evil they
believe that there is no life to kill
point is if we're having a conversation
with them we're talking in completely
different directions
now i guess the silver lining is that
those who aren't as firm in their
position can have their minds changed
but when it comes to those die-hard
abortionists what is the value in having
a conversation with them i have to
correct you here the die-hard
abortionists do not do not question that
the life is a life
i have found in my experience the
squishy pro-abortion people will try to
tell you well the life isn't really a
life well the baby's not really a baby
but the hardcore ones are the ones that
i read today that i showed you today on
tiktok and the ones that i've been
talking to and debating for the past few
weeks
they acknowledge or naomi wolf even she
may have changed her view on abortion
but in the 90s she said
if we want to defend abortion we have to
acknowledge the baby is a baby the
baby's alive and mommy needs to kill the
baby in all of the baby's humanity if
she wants to be equal to men
i'm paraphrasing her argument
those are the hardcore people and so the
value i think in having that
conversation
is to have it publicly
because
hope springs eternal on the human breast
maybe you will convince them
but even if not when you have that
debate publicly
you are showing people the logical
conclusions of the two sides the
premises and the logical conclusions of
the two sides
you can get rid of some of the nonsense
and some of the false information about
the abortion debate and then you just
come down to okay i think that we should
not merely live for our own whims and
wills and we should recognize
the eternal moral order and we should
not kill our babies versus i think we
should be the pro abortion side would
say i think we should be able to commit
any
evil that we that we want
if that is our will
and and if we will not even to call it
evil then we can do that too right that
those are the conclusions and so i think
that can be very helpful because it
shows people who are watching the debate
huh
i don't i haven't totally thought about
this thing but
that guy sounds kind of reasonable and i
basically seem to agree with his and
that lady sends like a stone cold
freaking killer psycho and so even
though i in my mind i agree with her
position she seems like a total psycho
and the reality of the situation is
making me think maybe that guy's right
and i think that can be persuasive to
people
on on the other side
when you're talking to the squishy
people in the middle and they're the
ones who say well who knows who knows
when life begins the mystery of human
life i think it's actually much easier
to convince them you say well
it's a human being we now know that the
egg and the sperm come together and they
cease to be
the egg and the sperm and they create a
new
different in-kind unique
human entity that is alive that
satisfies all of these scientifically
agreed upon characteristics of life so
no matter what you
think about whether or not it's okay to
kill these people you you have to
acknowledge two things
it's human and it's alive i've had two
big abortion debates on my youtube
channel in the last few weeks and both
of these gals who agreed to came on
admitted that
and there's they're defenders of
abortion
but at least they admitted
yeah okay you're right there's no
getting out of this
scientifically ontologically it's living
and it's human so i think it can be
productive but it's it's not always
productive in the way people think
sometimes it's productive for the people
listening to the debate itself
all right next voicemail back
hey michael my name is cooper i'm a huge
fan of the show i love what you guys do
at the daily wire
i want to ask you how do we as
conservatives deal with the crazy people
on their side my whole family is
conservative
and
during 2020 they went off the deep end
with everything that happened you know
this coronavirus the the election
all of that it made them start to buy
into a lot of other conspiracy theories
that aren't true
for example my mother is a flat earther
now
none of my family members believe that
we landed on the moon other than me they
thought that trump was still in control
and like
he was running things from the shadows
or whatever if only but i've shown them
evidence to disprove their theories
and they just don't listen to it so how
can i bring them back from insanity they
don't even listen to the daily wire
anymore
because they think that you guys aren't
far right enough i hope to get a
response
and i hope you have a wonderful day man
thanks for what you do even me i'm not
far right enough i'm to the right of
genghis khan but okay so first of all
the the place to begin is politics is a
team sport
politics involves loyalty and you don't
need to
feel embarrassed of the p ever on every
team there's going to be some people who
are a little out there and a little
weird and we all have our foibles you
don't need to feel embarrassed of the
people on your side to try to score
points with the people on the other side
there is no conspiracy theory held by
anyone on the right that is crazier than
the conspiracy theories held by the
mainstream left namely babies aren't
babies and
and boys are actually secretly girls
okay those are the craziest conspiracy
theories i've ever heard they're crazier
than the flat earth they're crazier than
we didn't go to the moon they're crazier
than anything i've ever heard from the
right now some people on the right will
fall into things that are just not true
i i wish that trump were still running
the country he's obviously not
so i i would if you begin i think
you can begin from two places it's more
of an attitudinal question than it is
even a
uh
substance question
if you begin from oh mom come on don't
say that you're gonna make us all look
stupid to the libs and then they're
gonna think we're crazy and i'm one of
the smart conservatives and don't say
that then she's going to recoil from you
and she's going to say well you're
probably in on the evil illuminati
freemason cabal too and so you know
you're
get out of here you
but if you come at it from hey mom look
yeah the libs are completely out of
their minds and they've lied to us about
everything and the difference between a
conspiracy theory and the truth these
days is about six to nine months so
that's true but you know the earth is
not flat actually and here's the
evidence for it and look but i wish
trump was still in charge but he's not
in charge and uh we can i don't try to
make him in charge again but
if you come at it from that perspective
if you if you think about politics more
as a distinction between your friends
and your allies and your enemies and
your opponents and you you realize that
that is just in a practical way that's
how you're going to begin the the art of
politics and that politics is not merely
loyalties and alliances but also has to
do with logic and has to do with reason
and has to do with objective truth but
you don't deny
the team sport aspect of it then i think
you're going to be more persuasive
so there are some conservatives who
their their first instinct is to throw
their own guys under the bus
and i just don't think that where i
think politically that's stupid and i i
don't think it's a particularly virtuous
way to conduct politics one more
question let's do a real mailbag one a
written one shannon hey michael you've
said recently that the ends don't
justify the means and you wouldn't
commit a sin to solve a larger problem i
have a question would you lie to a nazi
about jews hiding in your attic if you
are so strict in your deontology could
it not be argued that an otherwise
sinful act might be motivated by
goodwill and duty such as the nazi
example in your view how can there be
any just wars thanks and love the show
oh well those are two separate questions
in terms of the the nazis show up and
i'm hiding jews in my addict what do i
say to them
is a lie justified uh
i am with saints augustine and thomas
aquinas this issue has been debated
for the entire history of the west but
i'm with augustine and thomas aquinas i
do not think that lies are justified i
do i think that lies are intrinsically
wrong now
i might be able to use my language in
such a way that
i could convey something that is
true in itself
but that the nazis would not believe to
be true so you could say
uh if i if i were
near a hill
and they said or do you have any jews in
your house i can say i saw him running
up
i saw him i saw him running
and you point and you could you could
even point at the hill now you saw the
jew that you're hiding running up your
stairs
but the nazis could interpret that as uh
as he's running up the hill they might
take off that's possible now that even
that might be a little bit morally
suspect some people have made arguments
that lies can be justified and there are
there are serious philosophers who have
made lie have made arguments that a
certain kind of lie could possibly be
justified because people do not have the
that a lie does not involve
nearly conveying false information that
you know to be false but it is conveying
false information that you know to be
false to people who have the right to
know that information so if the people
don't have the right to know that
information then it's not really a lie i
think that reasoning is a little weak to
me
um now to your second question how can
there be just wars uh because people do
have a natural right to self-defense and
there uh
there is a
legitimate claim that our calls to be
peaceable and make peace among nations
is not a blanket license to allow the
cruel to rape the earth and so also
going back to my my good buddy saint
thomas aquinas uh this has been fleshed
out over the centuries and there is no
christian call
to pacifism
that has never never really been
understood in in the mainstream history
of christianity there is though to go
back also to my other dead friend cs
lewis he has an excellent essay on why
he's not a pacifist we're two minutes
over so i can't really get into it now
but that would be a good essay for
memorial day weekend reading and maybe
we'll get into it more next week i'm
michael knowles have a good at memorial
day we'll see you next time
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin